et l'on va revoir roger knobelspiess
mais cette fois à l'écran jean pierre
mocky offre un rôle à l'ancien détenu
mocky qui aime une chose par dessus tous
par dessus tout étonné et même choqué
son dernier film en tournage en ce
moment dans la région de massy réussira
sûrement
il s'appelle ville à vendre et il réunit
des acteurs aussi brillante différents
michel serrault jacqueline maillan
richard bohringer ou encore eddy
mitchell de nancy joël bharti
fascination pour les quelques 500
figurants lorrain présent sur le
tournage ils ont à leurs côtés un
casting exceptionnel bohringer cero eddy
mitchell valérie mairesse
sans oublier l'enfant du pays comme
novembre le personnage qui me proposait
qui est inquiétant passez moi
l'expression un fouille merde
j'aime assez bien ces personnages qui
essaient de savoir ce qui se passe
derrière les apparences
et puis c'est vrai que les partenaires
que j'ai appris
dont j'ai appris qu'il faisait partie du
film était prestigieux nouvelle profite
de cette météo pour entrer en scène
libéré en out 90 après 26 ans de prison
grâce à meaux qui il tente de se
réinsérer en tant que comédien comme les
gamins bohringer ou autres mickey rourke
un petit rôle excellent qui en appelle
d'autres
moi j'espère un vrai rôle un rôle qui ne
soit pas celui d'un très belle piste
pourfendeur du public du blocage mais le
rôle d'un homme qui s'est battu pendant
26 ans et et qui peut faire passer dans
à l'écran autre chose c'est-à-dire ma
résistance et était mon refus et je peux
transformer tout ça en je parle en
émotions bouleversement sûr qu'apple est
un acte de l'acteur du bouleversement
avec villa vendre mots qui tire un homme
du pétrin parallèlement il immortalise
site de geof dans quinze jours la
dynamite en aura eu raison